una visita de un viejo amigo el
presidente de eeuu joe biden llegó a
israel en su primera visita desde que
llegó a la casa blanca en 2021 una
bienvenida cargada de referencias
bíblicas y con constantes alusiones a la
profunda y sólida relación de ambos
países
[Música]
su relación con israel siempre ha sido
muy personal una vez usted se proclamó
como un sionista y dijo que no tenía que
ser judío para ser un sionistas y tenía
razón
lo digo nuevamente no necesitas ser
judío para ser un sionista esta es mi
décima visita y cada vez que tengo la
oportunidad de regresar a este país
donde las raíces del pueblo judío se
remontan a tiempos bíblicos es una
bendición porque la conexión trae
profundos
un dip
pero con una visita a la franja de gaza
también busca reafirmar a los palestinos
que eeuu está comprometido con una
solución de dos estados y mientras busca
promover la estabilidad de medio oriente
profundizar la integración de israel en
la región y contrarrestar la influencia
iraní este mismo miércoles antes de su
llegada la casa blanca informó sobre un
acuerdo entre tela de washington que
busca la cooperación para la innovación
tecnológica una alianza que plantea
soluciones a desafíos globales como el
cambio climático la medicina y la
agricultura
[Música]
durante su visita discutiremos temas de
seguridad nacional discutiremos sobre
construir una nueva arquitectura
económica para las naciones del medio
oriente siguiendo los acuerdos de
abraham y los logros de la cumbre de
négev
luego de reunirse con el presidente de
la autoridad nacional palestina en
cisjordania ocupada este viernes se
espera que biden aterrice en arabia
saudita y le pida al monarca de riad que
impulse a los aliados del golfo para que
amplíen la producción de petróleo se
genere más oferta con mayores
extracciones y así se reduzca el precio
de la gasolina inflado por la guerra en
ucrania